ae
o triunfo por ano taj granta indicador
da ge grande honra
a oi aip povo tá limpo por dito de
grandes ícones grandes e aí galera que
assistiu o planalto não vocês nunca pra
você que não sabem alguns dias atrás
duas semanas atrás eu fui um pixel
evento de gala na internet encontra a
galera de assistir era de retomar a xii
encontro que a conversa no palestra ao
apoio do padrinho e esse evento
aconteceu no rio de janeiro e adivinha
de quem eu fui abraão a wii breve fora
de tudo que faz sem falar em tese não
vou gravar um short nossa causa não
sabiam passa um boi passa jumento as
mães ao espancar todos os filhos que tem
pra chorar na hora que eu tô gravando a
desgraça já começou no aeroporto eu fui
lá no aeroporto e fui passar minha bolsa
de negócios é implementá lá passou de
boato foi passar o mp requer alguns
nerds equipe eu sei lá uma coisa fui lá
e tirei a casa e passei penedo borra eu
diria da música fiquei só de cueca
do passeio de btt adivinho que era a pôr
no prédio porque ele é da minha vaiando
e chutou para fora na linha sai da
pobreza uma pobreza não sai dele é muito
pobre a ser pobre e usa até a alma da
baiana ele usa aí que usar efeitos da
matéria na raia avaiana preconceito só
porque eles aquele eu tenho não posso
usar minha família bota coisa quando
passa o negócio tá falando se ao meu
filho que você tem um xampu viu eu não
sabia que não podia levar este depois na
bolsa de mão simplex agora não consegui
encontrar um nexo de não poder levar um
xampu nos acham que eu sou eu não sou
terrorista vão ser um terrorista não
você não conseguir levantar lá no meio
de todo mundo parado
lavar o cabelo de você e etah não viu
aqui é de chorar de rua de vocês aí pra
não tenha de fato é normal se
tem medo de avião e tal eu sei que é
normal que é normal terminar porque é
seguro e não é porque o transporte mais
seguro do mundo você entra ali dentro
ninguém sabe ninguém entra você chega ao
seu destino será em três horas em um dos
olhos e tal agora se você cair você
tomar no cu que eu acho engraçado quando
achei que treinar avião é que era um ou
se ela vai dar as instruções nem casa de
emergência em caso de emergência ela
fala no caso de emergência vai cair uma
mafiazinha na minha frente aí eu puxava
a liberar o fluxo do ar é só colocar na
cadeia irá normalmente respirar
normalmente
o avião estava caindo eu caí como é que
vai expirar normalmente ea pena possível
esperar normalmente é assistir a um jogo
do campeonato brasileiro ver que ficar
correndo da foto de anna aslan rabat mim
imagina desgraça do avião cair é
engraçado que ele falou pra gente também
que em caso de emergência pode ficar no
nosso tempo na cento é flutuante e se
cair na terra não se você cai na terra
pode chegar só sei que você super vai
flutuar no asfalto
o avião explodiu sem sair flutuando de
boa não é engraçado que eles falam muito
de segurança não chega a segurança é o
nosso o que a gente mais preza aqui nem
a meu irmão minha irmã é que a segurança
é o melhor pra você a xbox como usar
aquele sentindo uma fitinha que passa
aqui no negócio bateram na cabeça na
face e monitor fogão sintero o osso é
uma que outra aqui outra que botou aqui
no meio é é
isso não é o mais forte eu fico vai me
passar de avião a falar passagem mil
reais
falei com honra tal falar nada ainda dá
pra comprar vão comprar passador mês
como ele hoje mas eu vou comprar quando
eu terei que comprar país lá a taxa de
que para estudar no chão que taxas é de
que mil e duzentos reais taxa de
embarque no céu que lá e taxa de serviço
tinha 119 reais a taxa de serviço era
sempre r$19 quer saber os serviços que o
goleiro nesse avião água até porque eu
pedi deixam para me falar que eu paguei
r$119 pb água
luís que avance a tamco é essa que vale
r$119 cara que está no céu é mais
do céu é mais caro nem dizer o
nome da empresa ou não ficar calada para
não me comprometo não vou falar não de
empresa nenhum dubai tóquio gol
foi basicamente isso mas foi
basicamente isso eu adorei tem o pixel
conheciam as pessoas muito gente boa
como pe onde do canal com bush que esse
canal aqui você pode clicar aqui para se
inscrever no canal dele eu tenho certeza
que vocês vão adorar conhecer alice
portugal conhecido luisão eu conheci o
joelho esquerdo a festa é conhecido
tássio é um cara que tem uma página
muito legais e aí conheci iberê normal
do mundo que esse canal aqui se você
quiser visitar se inscrever lá também
pode se inscrever se você gostou desse
vídeo você sabe né se dá um like você já
me ajuda muito caso seja a primeira vez
que vê no vídeo meu só clicar em se
inscrever aqui e continue não só saber o
que é que você comente em baixa pela
vergonha que você já passou enquanto
viajava de avião de carro de ônibus e de
jumento qualquer coisa eu queria
agradecer a você que segue que o meu
canal que agradecer a todo mundo que
está aqui sempre presente toda quarta e
todo sábado porque a gente conseguiu
bater a marca das 10 milhões de
exibições em menos de um ano 10 milhões
10 milhões de soles
é uma coisa muito importante eu quero
que você faça é que você me siga no
twitter míssil no facebook ensino
italiano não é questão de número é
porque é mesmo vídeo saia pessoa não
sabe que sair eu fico perguntando e aí
já teve nova chance e ninguém vê e ouve
naquela tarde ali naquela noite lá então
é muito importante você me seguir no
twitter aqui ó podem seguir aqui podem
seguir no instagram para seguir no
facebook os três links estão em seguida
vêm aqui na descrição do vídeo é só ir
lá agora em fazer isso e é nóis outra
coisa eu tô com a parceria com a canon é
uma loja que vai dar 10% de desconto pra
se você comprar lá pela minha parte da
minha página esta que está aqui também é
o primeiro nunca descrição do vídeo é
então se você comprar qualquer coisa tem
negócio da academia planeta tem roupa
tem um monte de coisa séria e logo mais
vou voltar com os produtos dela aqui pra
vocês verem realmente não está lá no
site você quiser comprar relacionamento
o calça blusa ou passei lá porque coisa
seja marlon e hanói falou onde estava a
galera está aqui do meu feitio
o maior evento de vela sociais do
maracanã
ela foi enganada mas o como os ônibus
quem gosta dessa senhora bem-vindo coisa
então mesmo só não foi só um maluco
imagina só pelé e roda que o rio volte a
ficar como é
só senhor vai fazer você feliz agora
a mãe é assim
então não tinha muita gente não sabe é
você menina declarou eu acho legal
foi engraçado mas anthony annan foi só
tomou o troco assim a presença melhor
ainda na campanha campeã e por aí
tocando no canal a yoggi lezin é uma
fênix é mais um famoso no brasil e tenho
também que o campeão é o fierro
youtube.com o bairro de luti que hoje
projeto faça diferente da festa
então clique na garrafa d'água pra ir
para o canal do júnior a mais
é isso aí insulto bom
todos legais ea china
não mostro pra mim só olha você decora o
sinte uma peça cruel para baixo nunca
mais o mesmo mas também as causas só vai
confirmar o rei não tá em cima com essa
com certeza ficará mesmo em cima porque
também está embaixo acontece na frança
para mim palavra mágica de hoje
essa casa não foi na bola mas depois não
foi junto para conseguir droga a ser
vendida a luta principal o próprio
button só em três tipos se chama a
coligação apenas 605
também chamada vai toma no ranking se
não for eu falar que mais uma fez com
quase todo mundo aqui nessa sala cara
o capitão
zelda motivo
ae
aí o demônio